ce sont des bras en liane banian pas
besoin pour que l'entourage permettant
les histoires neuf pays iran la pitié
force tampon dit
ti pas ti pas nelly cases à lire à
l'année dans l'univers son personnage
informe saint denis la descente la
société pour rester au sommet si madame
la demande qu'à peine ali 6 14 au départ
c'est un madame t y es est dans la ville
de saint-denis qu'un sdf était un
personnage vraiment particulier les il
était populaire à la réunion et tout
demoun a entendu un jour il pense parler
de 6,14 et aujourd'hui dans la société
nana tati 14 en fait de toute façon par
tout le monde en somme un saignement pas
si 14 c'est un peu spécial
elle paye embarrasse pas à cause des
cadeaux moon avec un ti cats est
pareillement martin vient pointer ce
manque et pas trop loin ça cne licasale
d'antan longtemps quand il était petit
en fait moi tu aies joué dans la com au
moment et au moment des termes comme ça
ma fille ou les parts et 6 14
ils étaient bien moins ça tout le temps
lité été cassée cuit quoi et en fin de
compte mal à grandi avec ça dans mon
tête et un journal interroge à main à
cause dit 14 ses coûts et aimant l'art
on a moins content que l'été liée à la
question de l'errance et et de voilà
d'où ça nous place à nous dans la
société dans nous-mêmes de notre
identité dans notre réflexion par
rapport au monde
[Musique]
être plairait
cossa
aussi il pousse un beau gars madame
l'orgue le corps sommeil bec par élément
où ces deux mots ni dessine traps bas
logan nazelle sorte de hope oublie
tracas s'appliqua à lydiane ou des fois
là pas besoin d'aller loin pour mettre
en mouvement pour trouver de place
écoute gaillard pour en demanderont
2 demain
[Musique]